hi
and welcome to sec 212 where we'll cover
how you can take control of security
with the security command center
i'm andy chang a product manager in
google's cloud security team
and i'm here with my co-presenter kyle
olive hi i'm kyle olive a product
manager on the google cloud security
command center team
kyle will be covering some of the
built-in vulnerability and threat
detectors in detail later in this talk
in addition we'll be showing you an
example of how violia a multinational
based in france operating utilities
water and waste management and energy
services has integrated
security command center into their
security workflow
staying in control of your security is
hard as cloud adoption grows
and your teams get even more agile the
accelerated velocity of cloud
development
means that you have increasing numbers
of dynamic resources and services
being deployed expanding your attack
surface and potentially expanding both
the risks that you have to address
and the scale and complexity of your
estate traditional tools needed
also seem to endlessly multiply and make
it hard for you to drive consistency
and get one unified view of your
security posture
as enterprises move from on premise to
public cloud environments
three common concerns are top of mind
how do i get full visibility and how do
i get an accurate assessment of my
attack surface
my security posture and my compliance
state
can i continue to detect and respond to
the threats that are most relevant and
important to me
how do i learn to use and deal with the
additional complexity of new
architectures
policy systems technologies and the
services available in public clouds
and across all three of these how do i
keep on top of all of these things
as the scope of services and the size of
deployments from my teams continually
grow
and increases finally will i need
to know how to manage an ever-growing
set of security tools with disparate
interfaces and capabilities in order to
keep ahead of these challenges
or can i use something native and built
it
security command center provides you a
single place to control the security of
your estate on google cloud
security command center offers a unified
set of capabilities
that enables you consistent and
continuous organization-wide visibility
detection and enables you to respond all
from one place
leveraging the best of google cloud
security expertise
with all the services managed by google
and at google scale
security command center premium
addresses your challenges by providing
you with a single place
for organizational level control over
the built-in threat
prevention and threat detection
capabilities offered by google cloud
from one unified place you can manage
and review findings related to your
security posture
your active threats the underlying
assets being impacted
and their metadata and the different
types and classifications of data
potentially at risk
all through a google managed system that
automatically scales and deploys
with the growth of your organization
security command center offers a single
consistent place
for you to enable which security
services should be enabled where
by default all resources supported by
security command center
are automatically monitored and covered
by threat prevention and detection
capabilities
so as your developers spin up new
projects and your organization grows
these policies get applied automatically
reducing the danger of an
inadvertent blind spot in your
understanding of your attack surface
with security command center premium you
can continuously monitor your security
posture
monitor your asset configurations
against common misconfigurations
and against compliance controls like cis
and pci
you can automatically detect
vulnerabilities in your public web
applications
from the oaf's top 10 and in addition
you can detect and protect
against active threats through real-time
log and cluster analysis
to find bad actors and stop them in real
time
i'll turn now turn it over to kyle to
provide you details on each of these
built-in capabilities
keeping your deployment secure is an
ongoing challenge but as andy mentioned
security command center includes several
capabilities
that help you increase your scope of
coverage understand your security
posture
and enable you to become more secure
over time
we'll spend a little bit of time going
over each of these capabilities before
diving into a real life demonstration
of how you can use security command
center in your organization
first let's talk about the capabilities
designed to help you understand and
improve
your security posture security health
analytics
monitors and analyzes your
infrastructure configurations
for known insecurity configurations and
configurations that are not complying
with compliance controls
security health analytics offers a broad
scope of coverage out of box
and with minimal configuration you
simply turn it on for your org and get
coverage for any existing or any new
projects that get spun up
our goal with security health analytics
is to cover the broader scope of google
cloud services
leveraging google security know-how to
provide detections and recommendations
that will make customers more secure
across storage
compute and several other google cloud
services
every detection includes the metadata
you need to triage that finding
and act on it including context-specific
remediation instructions
additionally we've recently improved
security health analytics to have an
even tighter integration
with your resource configurations
detecting changes and configurations in
real time
and allowing you to react and respond to
critical events before a breach can
occur
security health analytics can detect
some of the most impactful
misconfigurations
like public buckets or open firewalls
while also providing more nuanced
security recommendations
around networking logging and monitoring
these recommendations come from our
security teams and many of them are the
same guidelines that google itself puts
into place
the selection of detections found here
are only a small subset
of the total number of detections that
are available and that scope of coverage
will continue to increase over time
one of the most exciting things we've
added this year is the ability for
security health analytics to perform
continuous compliance monitoring
identifying resources that are known to
be misconfigured
against compliance controls from the cis
dcp benchmark
pci dss iso 27001
nist 853 and more these findings are
surfaced through dashboards that can be
filtered and scoped by projects or
folders
giving you control over how you assess
your environment
these reports can be a starting point
for remediative actions or export it out
as a csv
that can be used to track your
compliance state over time
but your security posture is made up of
more than just your resource
configurations
it's also important to monitor against
vulnerabilities in your web applications
security command center includes web
security scanner for that purpose
web security scanner automatically
detects and scans your exposed public
web applications
for the most common and impactful
vulnerabilities found in web apps
like security health analytics there is
minimal configuration overhead required
here
you just turn on the service and
security command center will
automatically detect
and configure web application scans for
apps running on gae
gke or gce these scans will crawl your
public web applications in order to
detect
some of the most severe vulnerabilities
found in web applications including
vulnerabilities from categories of the
oauth top 10 like cross-site scripting
and security misconfigurations
these again are the same tools that
google uses to protect and scan our own
web applications
and are making these detections
available to security command center
customers
all of the findings we just talked about
can be centrally managed from the
vulnerabilities dashboard
or via a single security command center
api
each finding is associated with the
severity and other additional metadata
allowing you to assess the potential
impact of a finding and triage it for
action
finally as mentioned each finding
includes context-specific remediation
instructions
that you can quickly act on yourself
automate against or copy into a ticket
that you can assign to a project owner
but sometimes despite all our best
efforts malicious actors manage to
compromise
some part of a deployment security
command center also
provides you the tools you need to
detect these intrusions and respond to
them in real time
first up we have event threat detection
at google we have dedicated threat
intelligence groups analyzing activities
on the internet
for the latest threat signals not only
to protect ourselves but also our
customers
event threat detection leverages those
threat signals to provide an enhanced
level of detection
allowing you to catch more incidents
these detections happen in real time
as soon as the law gets generated
allowing you to respond to incidents in
seconds
as your logs are generated event threat
detection monitors them analyzing
entries from your audit logs
your syslogs and your network logs from
there we apply our detection logic
and use google's threat intelligence to
identify malicious actors performing one
of several types of activities event
threat detection can detect activities
related to malware or point mining
running on your systems
it can detect active data exploration or
im abuse
and will be able to leverage user
behavior analytics to detect compromises
on accounts
and alert you to that activity and the
scope of these detections will only
increase over time
google's expertise can also be leveraged
in other ways
like with our container threat detection
capabilities now in security command
center
container threat detection is an
exciting new capability available in
security command center
at its core it's a linux security module
baked into cost and gke
that can detect incidents occurring on
your gke workloads in real time
once again security command center
handles the management of these
deployments
automatically enabling container threat
detection on clusters and projects per
your settings
as soon as those clusters get spun up
removing the overhead that regularly
comes with this kind of protection
once enabled container threat detection
monitors real-time changes on your
workloads
to detect incidents like the execution
of added binaries
new linked libraries or when a cluster
suddenly opens the reverse shell to the
internet
all signs of a compromise in just
seconds you can alert on an incident and
even take
automated action against it for an
example of that we'll now switch over to
a demo from gamble care at
fiolia kian will walk us through how
violia leverages security command center
to respond to vulnerabilities
automatically in real time
in a way that can be extended to any of
the detections we just talked about
let's take a look
hi everyone i'm guillain blakir i'm
google developer expert on cloud
platform i'm also a screenmaster and
lead architect
at veria veria it's a major french
company environmental company focus on
water waste
and energy present in 50 countries in
the world
and with more than one hundred and
seventy thousand employees
the real work work with more than seven
years with
google cloud and today we have more than
4000
projects on gcp with internal and
external people and partners that work
on the platform
for building and rolling solution in
production
today managing the security is a is a
challenge
for us because we are a small team in
paris and we have a lot of people a lot
of countries
several times on uh seven said different
affinity with the security and we have a
lot of work to
to do for example when you have to
review the uh up
the final rules and to see what is open
too widely will perform batches every
three
three three months and we give you all
this all the five
rules we contact the
the project owner to review with
them if it's normal or not that we have
this rule and so on
and to fix it or to witness this these
rules
it's a lot of work every three months
it's not very interesting
it's time consuming and we perform this
only every three months
and in three months it can happen a lot
of things
now with security command center
every event in the cloud are scanned by
the security command center and when the
findings
is is fine it is published on pub sub
and the message is consumed
by cladren in clarendon we have
implemented
two action on a message the first one is
to publish
a message in slack the second one is to
use the google api for
an immediate action on the finding for
example to revoke some authorization
on the buckets we have in
our roadmap to implement other things
for example to send an email on the
findings
to open a ticket in our ticketing tool
servicenow
at veria and we
can also store only the relevant finding
for violia and then to build the
dashboard on this
findings and at the end we can provide a
global view on the security
to the security team to the manager to
the auditors and so on
so now i would like to put onto a demo
of what we have
done today with the security command
center and here i'm the firewall rules
just go on the findings here
we are in the landing page for the
findings and
we can filter by security but my
preferred view is
here the finding change why because you
can see
what's it's new what's that what are the
new findings
in your uh environment in your
in your context uh the last hours last
day the last week and so on as very
efficient
for working with with this so
now imagine i have a user that would
like to share some documents
with customers and partners
there's a lot of people involved and the
user won't don't want to grant
all the users one by one in the
[Music]
in in the console for this user want to
make the bucket public and to share it
widely at the area we don't want this
because we consider that
the data stored in our buckets are
various data and at least confidential
data and
we don't want to share it with anybody
that's why we can apply for example an
organization
an organization policy named domain
restriction
sharing that prevents you to grant all
users and all authenticated users to the
buckets
but the side effect of this organization
policy is you can't
grant all users and all authenticated
users
to claren cat function and app engine
and that's why with this organization
policy we can't
make public our api and our website
or we can rightly the project for making
public our api
and our website with clarence function
app engine but
we also wait list our bucket and can
grant all users and all authenticated
users to the buckets
and we don't want this now with a
security command center and the
financing findings we can do this
for example here i have a bucket
and i would like to share publicly this
is
this is okay i will add all users
here and i will share all the
objects uh of my uh
bucket when i save i have a one message
and i'll say
now your bucket is public and yes you
say okay
i'm aware of this and
a finding is fine by security command
center a
message is published to the topic
and our children instance
publish a message on slack hey we have a
finding here and we have removed
automatically the
authorization of the bucket we can go
back to the bucket you can see here it's
publicly accessible
but in fact not if i refresh the page
the bucket the authorization has been
removed automatically by calling the
google api so now we don't have a
problem
only two or three three three three
seconds
be between the the public access and the
relocation by
uh the calendar instance
same thing for for example with the
firewall rules i would like to
use the various resources and my
professional accounts
to build for example a minecraft server
for playing with my friends and my
family
and i've created a computer instance
deployed my manifest
instance and now i have to create a file
rules
so i would create a file rules here i
can name heat
if i'm stupid i name it my minecraft but
i'm stupid and i can um
allow all the instances in the network i
open it
very widely because my friends my family
and a lot of people
and i would like to open it on the port
10 000 because it's my server
hold on it now i will click on create
and as before in few seconds i can see
here in the search channel oh you have
an open firewall
findings and i don't know what
what to do i don't know if it's normal
or not
not normal and i can ask the security
team to have a review on these
findings why because when you have
buckets open publicly on internet you
can
immediately download the content and the
data link is instant
when you open a strange file of
transport
on firewall rules you are it's maybe
maybe some intruder can use it and
enter into the system but it's not
instant it can take
days weeks or months for this and you
can
take more time to review the rules and
now i can see
what's happened i click on the link and
i can see
or i will name minecraft open on
internet on this port
no it's not normal i have to delete it
and now it's uh i can react immediately
on
a file rules open and i don't have to
perform batches every three months as
before
now the platform is more secure
it's quicker to react on the events with
the premium version we have
more and more findings and we can
fine-tune what we like to allow and to
disallow on our platform
and it's helped us a lot in our
day-to-day job
it's less boring as before so this
evolution and this real-time
notification
is very very great for us at this area
thank you as guillaume showed in the
demo viola has been able to integrate
security command center premium
into its security workflow and remove
the toil of
batch assessments for vulnerability to
moving to a continuous vulnerability
assessment
with proactive alerting security command
center premium addresses the challenges
of giving you the continuous visibility
of your security posture across your
ever-changing
asset estate that you need provides you
near real-time detection of
vulnerabilities and of threats that can
impact your
system and it reduces the complexity and
toil for you
to protect your estate and maintain a
strong security posture on google cloud
security command center premium is
provided through an annual
all-you-can-use subscription
which empowers you to have your security
scale
with your growth regardless of how large
your organization grows
to learn more about security command
center premium please go to
cloud.google.com
security dash command dash center
now let's bring kyle back we'd like to
thank you so much for the opportunity
you gave us to present to you
how you can take control of your
security with the cloud security command
center thanks for watching